okay good to see you thanks for joining
us
um now talk to me about how many people
we've managed to get out
well the figure I'm going to give you is
the figure that we know to be accurate
from late last night that's 536.
and the reason I'm saying I'm giving
that figure from late last night is
there are planes in the air with British
Nationals on them there are British
Nationals in Khartoum who are under the
umbrella of protection of the British
armed forces and rather than giving a
kind of drip free drip feed I think it's
better to tell you what we know to be
accurate give periodic updates uh but we
are we are seeing a steady flow of
British Nationals and a few others uh a
few Nationals of other countries being
evacuated through the Airhead that we're
facilitating through the air base at
Wadi signal in uh Khartoum Aman on the
ground
says that even if the search fire ends
he is confident that the airlifts should
continue you suggested last night
potentially that's not the case
what's your understanding well
to we had always planned to evacuate
under whatever circumstances were on the
ground
the ceasefire that we had called for in
conjunction with our International
allies has made it considerably easier
and we cannot predict exactly what will
happen when that ceasefire
ends but what we do know is it will be
much much harder potentially impossible
so what we're saying to British
Nationals is if you're hesitant if
you're weighing up your options are
strong strong strong advice is to go to
Woody Sydney whilst the ceasefire is up
and running there are planes there is
capacity we will lift you out are not
able to make those same assurances once
the ceasefire has ended so so if you're
planning to move move now okay
suggestions from our people on the
ground certainly in Cyprus speaking to
people down there this CSI could be
extended for a further 72 hours what do
you know about that well look we're
pushing we push for the original
ceasefire we're pushing to have the
ceasefire extended we're pushing with
our International Partners leaders in
the region to have a permanent peace
settlement but the point I'm making is I
can't guarantee any of those things if
they happen that's great that's what we
push the extent I don't want to
speculate because because my worry is if
people are having to make difficult
decisions and of course they are yeah if
they're basing those decisions on a
belief that this ceasefire will continue
and then it doesn't they put themselves
in a more dangerous situation so my
strong advice is to ER on the side of
caution take advantage of what we know
which is the ceasefire is currently
holding even though we don't know
whether it will hold for the full
duration rather than relying on what
might not happen which is an extension
of the ceasefire which of course we're
pushing for okay talk to me about what
the Germans are up to
um a couple of things they have
suggested I'm sure you've seen the
reports by our colleagues at the BBC
suggesting that the Brits landed in
cartoon without the authority of the
Sudanese and as a result that impacted
on others who would other countries that
were trying to get their own citizens
out at the time so I've had exchanges
with my German foreign minister
colleague
I know my Ben Wallace and the military
have had exchanges with their I don't
recognize that reporting that's not what
has been communicated to us that's not
that's not so uh and in fact just before
coming on uh on air I had a conversation
with Ben Wallace he and I have been
working hand in hand throughout this
operation even when I was in the Pacific
and he assures me that we had
um we had permissions to overfly Sudan
those
reports have not been raised with me
they've not been raised with him will
you look at it of course we will of
course we will fine let me also um you
talked about the German foreign minister
they're also suggesting yesterday
um that this quote unbelievable uh
Berlin wouldn't leave civilians to their
own devices and that unlike other
countries its evacuation had included
all citizens proper pop at the Brits
there again I don't know whether I don't
know
why would he say she say that well uh so
I don't know quite what uh information
that is based on
um the first lift that we took out took
quite understandably uh British uh
Diplomat
um but we also of course supported a
small number of Nationals from other
countries because they at the time were
co-located with us so the very first
flight that we took out included uh
Nationals of other countries
uh um other countries have helped
evacuate British Nationals we are
currently helping to evacuate Nationals
from other countries I of course will
look at what what information she has
been given and make sure nothing is Lost
in Translation but right from the start
this has been an international
Cooperative effort of course our first
priority well that must be frustrating
then we're saying stuff like that so
what I so what I understand what I'm you
know and this is not the first time I've
had to deal with a major repatriation is
information uh given in good faith is
often cluttered sometimes slightly
inaccurate as politicians just like we
are today we're often pressed for
answers and we give answers which we
believe are right and we believe uh in
good faith but then turn out not to be
completely accurate so I know that we
have supported our International
colleagues just as they have supported
us might we have to leave some people
who want to come out behind well
it's really as I say it's really really
difficult to predict what might happen
over the next couple of days
what I now know what I know as of today
is we have airframes on the ground we
have capacity we are calling people
forward we are using every Communication
channel available to us now is the time
to move because when the ceasefire ends
my ability to give the kind of
limited assurance that I can give now
might go and we might not be able to
evacuate so please please please so if
you get to the Airfield today you can
come out we have capacity we have
airframes uh we have a number of flights
going today
um and so what I'm saying is get to the
airport now whilst we can still
facilitate and if you get to the airport
today you might not get out today but
you will get out well as I say at the
moment we have we have capacity we have
airframes and we have a flights plan
throughout the day so so move now
um
I wondered if you could talk to me as
well in a little bit more detail about
what's going to happen once
potentially people who are in uh coming
from Sudan try to get on a small boat
and come to the UK well there is war and
conflict uh all over the world there are
literally millions upon millions of
people who are upon me who are in
countries uh plagued by War and we
recognize that we cannot we we cannot
host everybody who is in a country
played by War uh last night
uh we made sure thank you last night we
made sure that we had the powers that we
needed to deal with the unprecedented
levels of illegal migration facilitated
by people traffickers particularly
talking about Sudan but but the point is
Sudan sadly is not the only place in the
world that is uh talk about Sudan if
they can no no actually because it's
really important Sudan is not the only
country uh suffering from uh conflict
and so picking out Sudan because it
happens to be in the news I think
diminishes the suffering of other people
around the world firstly and secondly we
have to remember we have to remember
there are there are millions upon
millions of people who are either
fleeing conflict or who are fleeing
economic privations you mentioned
Ukraine that's really important we
created safe and legal routes uh for
Ukraine the uh the Home Secretary has
said that we will con and indeed the
Prime Minister the rest of the
government have said that we'll we will
create safe and legal routes are not at
this point going to speculate exactly uh
the numbers of nature of those roots uh
but the point is we make we need to make
it clear we have always had safe and
legal routes thousands tens of thousands
are illegal to come over on a boat tens
of thousands of people have come here
through safe and legal routes
but where people have illegal migration
facilitated by people illegal though
France actually why are you saying it's
illegal it's not illegal because we have
legal roots
and we have Roots which are are clearly
illegal so you you say coming over on a
boat is illegal
on a small boat yes so why don't we
arrest them because because
the the the point the points well we
take people into when we take people
into uh basically the the protection of
the UK State uh we have to process them
uh and what we're doing is we're
creating equally as soon as they get on
British so I'll arrest them well look uh
semantically the point is so the point
is that we are uh we are making sure
that we
um are now able to process those people
process them more quickly more
effectively so that we can support the
people who have a a completely
legitimate reason fleeing probably
conflicting persecution for example the
people who ultimately will have a right
to be here from the people who should
not I'm very pleased that we've been
working very very closely with the
Albanian government uh foreign
and and they have been very very
proactive but uh what we have what we
have now got is a very clear route
whereby albanians who have the right to
be here but I can't we can't just
collaborate no no no did it yesterday
extensively with your one of your
previous uh one of your colleagues if I
could read it like that in fact it was
none other than the Home Secretary
herself who was sat just where you are
and she says that a lot of people coming
over on small boats are at odds with
British values and cannibalize the uh
UK's compassion
um do you agree well one of the things
that we we absolutely have seen is that
the British people are hugely
compassionate the numbers of people who
have welcomed ukrainians into their
homes the numbers of people
odd with British are they not with
British values okay let me answer let me
answer uh the the people from many many
parts of the world who have uh come into
the UK over many many decades have
integrated fully and successfully in
British Society we've always been a
generous Nation but we can also see that
there are people who are proactively
abusing our hospitality and and a
national character is very much like a
personal character people are generous
of spirit but if we see people abusing
that generosity it erodes trust it
erodes trust in the immigration system
it erodes trust and what we want to do
is we want to reinforce the British
People's Natural hospitality and
generosity we want to support that and
protect that and we also want to protect
the country from people who seek to
abuse it yeah including those people
traffickers who are who are who are
perpetrating the most evil uh okay using
people as product and trying to make
money off human suffering another couple
of thoughts British Red Cross
um saying that the humanitarian
situation back in Sudan is catastrophic
what are we doing to help well
the best thing the first thing to try
and do when there's a humanitarian
disaster
as a potentially could unfold in Suzanne
is end the conflict
um a conflict makes everything better
sorry it makes everything worse uh food
insecurity uh danger to individuals so
to make things better the best thing you
can do is push for a ceasefire
um we've been doing that I've been doing
that I've communicated with the generals
directly and through intermediaries we
will continue to do so uh exactly the
nature of the humanitarian support that
is needed we will have a better
assessment over time may I just ask you
one very quick question to defend one of
your colleagues or otherwise Steve
Barkley is he a bully absolutely not
Steve I've worked with him on a number
of occasions he has made a statement
making it absolutely clear that he that
have been no uh uh reports uh his
statement is clear and completely
unambiguous it uh and I am
completely convinced that that is uh
accurate okay you're an impossibly busy
man we must let you get on with your day
thank you very much for joining us thank
you